good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast brought to you by
betterhelp it doesn't matter who you are
or what you have life can be pretty damn
hard and without a healthy mind it's
even harder check out online therapy
with betterhelp.com toast and be on your
way to a little more ease welcome back
to the morning toast everyone hey jax
how you doing hi i'm good because it's a
tuesday that does feel like a monday but
then you're reminded it's a tuesday and
that's just a fabulous feeling
how are you
i'm broken thank you so much for asking
i have returned from the i believe what
is
factually known as like the highest
altitude in the country is it well it
has to be because like the way that i
was feeling there's no way you could get
any higher like you felt higher than
utah oh yeah no no totally right and
aspen are like
really really high like utah is nothing
you'd have nothing when you go to utah
do you feel anything
no i guess not no i just like assume
i've got lungs of
steel no but i have the opposite of
lungs of steel and like it was like i
was choking the whole i definitely don't
it's probably just cause like you toss
pretty much at sea level and yeah
my lungs aren't working that hard my
lungs like we're working in overdrive
i'm so happy to be back at sea level
like i love it here i take back
everything i've ever said about new york
it was really hard for me to breathe
like not breathe actually but like move
yeah you just get out of breath pretty
quickly yeah like at the wedding you
know i was trying to do my best simple
dancing and i just got winded it's like
you're pregnant
yes
oh my god yeah that's how it feels like
you just get winded over the most menial
tasks and then there's the k you know
the thing of the altitudes
okay which is
high altitude when you go from like
drastic changes like you get really bad
gas
is that your excuse no no i'm telling
you it was a thing and like everyone was
talking about it the altitude so
everyone like you have it going there or
coming back or both just the adjustment
like the whole time like
you're just and like the way that i
experienced it was different from the
way i was talking other people who were
experiencing it like some of them
noticed like you know a unique fragrance
to their brand of toots and others were
just noticing the frequency in which
they were tuning to be you know a lot
heavier so i just just as for the
altitudes because like when we landed me
and ben were in the car and like all the
windows were down and it was just like
farted out all the air pressure no and i
was like oh my god like i'm like farting
so much and then on my stories um i was
talking about the altitude and people
were giving me great recommendations
oxygen in a can like a lifesaver yeah
and someone was like the altitudes are
real like if you notice you're farting a
lot like it's a thing and i was like oh
my god i was like in the car i literally
couldn't stop i'm dying i've never heard
that before what a fun fact nature is
hysterical hysterical so it was a smelly
wedding
no i'm kidding it was beautiful and it
was really really fun and it's just some
you know totally red's like something
you gotta see
yeah no you sent some stunning photos
that definitely had me scratching that
tully right itch yeah yeah it gets itchy
it it was feeling a little itchy and
that is definitely somewhere i would
like to go yeah that's beautiful at some
point in my life you should and you're a
skier you know i am not this season
unfortunately you guys want to hit the
slopes without me but yeah i should
i should try to ski
somewhere other than utah sometime know
i'm just a creature of habit and i love
that deer valley at the end of the day
isn't it all just a mountain like you
know some mountains are different than
others but then they say like deer
valley is the best skiing in the country
so it's like why would i go anywhere
else it's a direct flight direct flight
direct flight on the way there um we did
have to take a one-stop flight
and it was um
grueling it was grilling it was like
about a 12-hour travel day but you know
you love the bride and groom and you do
anything for them yeah so i stand by
that and on the way there is better than
on the way home because like you're
still excited to get there so you just
have like more yeah
well on the way home i just kind of gave
up and flew private but yeah i feel you
yeah no but that's better than if you
flew private there and a one-stop on the
way home oh no on the way home it's like
you're depressed you're hungover like
you've got like alcohol anxiety you're
like if i don't get home in five minutes
like i'm not gonna be okay yes so you
did it right i did it right um before we
dive in because there's a lot to talk
about we haven't had a show since the
first day thank you everyone for giving
me the two days off
they were both spent traveling um
i think we should discuss uh what's
there's been so much going on in the
world and really devastating news coming
out of afghanistan yeah the news has
been extremely upsetting um
the news of the 13 marines who were
killed in afghanistan was just
heartbreaking i think it
clouded over everyone's weekend 100 i
can't stop thinking about it can
something about them what's going on in
afghanistan now we've left but like
there are americans still there there
are service dogs still there they're
afraid it's like in major danger like
allies translators um
equipment it's a really
scary thing that's happening um
and i just like feel really like sad for
the families of everyone of the 13
service members who passed away and
actually there have been gofundme set up
that are completely verified like
gofundme made them yeah and they've been
in contact with the family so if you're
looking for a way to like support i know
one of the service members um was like
three weeks out from having their first
baby yeah so
if you go to gofundme twitter they have
like a whole thread and you posted it to
your stories i saw it yeah which you
know it's so hard like when something
like this happens like you just want to
donate and then you never know like
people set up gofundmes that are not
affiliated with the family so the fact
that gofundme like is handling it i very
much appreciate it yeah yeah um and then
there was also a hurricane in louisiana
um i do believe it was downgraded so it
wasn't as terrible as it could have been
but it's still like people have no power
and their homes are flooded so far
louisiana toasters i hope you're okay
and
it's just been a cr like a crazy like
tragic like non-stop nonstop so much
tragedy but we're here to attempt
attempt but it gets harder
everything like it really does but i
will segue because i have a gift for you
what
uh-huh it's the gift that i that we
thought maybe we got the same one yes
okay and it arrived and of course i
don't like check my packages when they
come i like leave them in my foyer for a
few days that's sociopathic i'm just
like the laziest person alive oh my god
when i see those boxes first i'm so
excited to see what's in them and second
of all like i'm like a declutter if i
see one morsel of something in my like
foyer is it for your foyer it depends
sorry french yes foyer um it drives me
nuts like i hate things
yes i am just so lazy so i wait until
there's a ton of boxes and then i'm like
okay like i'm gonna get them all that's
insane it's insane so you should have
had your gifts last week it was already
here oh i guess that's like people who
leave like their emails unopened and
opened those people are psychotic i
leave need like emails that i need to
get to unopened of course you don't have
twenty thousand email like notifications
no no i hate when people do that that's
so crazy and i'm sorry
it's not a personality trait to have
like a thousand unread text messages
like just open them oh i mean text
messages is like a little cooler because
that means like a thousand people texted
you but with emails it's like all junk
mail like that's not cool i think if you
have to like you know if you need the
validation of people thinking a thousand
people texted you like you should look
inward yeah i i do agree with that i
just don't think it's like a cool thing
like oh man i have so many texts like i
can never respond i'm so busy like
you're not you're not busy at all answer
your text message just call your mom
back yeah i do agree with that okay
ready for your gift yes in true us
fashion it is not wrapped of course of
course of course
it's upside down so water bottle open
your eyes i don't know where you'd hold
on
[Laughter]
the water bottles they have on love
island oh
you're lying oh my god i'm like a water
bottle you're lying
i got a text wait i don't believe you
how do you know oh it says love island
and it says your name on it just like on
love island hold on
let me get my lacroix oh wait no no no
you should rinse it out first oh come on
just let me use it okay but you guys can
just oh honestly
smell it it definitely smells like oh my
gosh you're pregnant don't make you
nauseous okay thank you yeah it doesn't
okay i'll wait i'll wash it through the
dishwasher oh my god i love this i'm not
gonna lie i was confused at first oh and
it comes with a little they're always
like walking around with it like a purse
you know yeah how do i oh my god this is
a great did you get yourself one no just
for you you're so selfless why
um because i just saw it and thought of
you
i love it like i really do
oh my god edit says love island you want
to plug the website if somebody wants to
get one so i just found it from in the
app they said like you can you know you
can buy their neon signs in the app like
you're lying similar and then it also
said you could get the water bottle so i
was like the second that the show ended
i deleted the app same second i have to
be downloaded and i place this order but
the company is frank and green i guess
who makes their water bottles oh my god
thank you so much i really love this
i'm so glad and you know what i need to
start drinking water i've been enjoying
water bottles a lot recently we got like
the awesome hydro drugs and i also like
still use my water bottle for my
wellness retreat and it's just like you
drink so much more water do you
fill it up once and then it like you
will drink more water oh my god i'm like
freaking out like i love this i'm so
glad i don't like no i don't even want
to drink out of it like it's perfect
oh my god i'm dying thank you so much
it's a great gift yes so 8 out of 10.
i'm not going to lie i was like why did
this beach get me a water bottle i don't
even drink water you could put anything
in it totally diet coke
spreads
spirits use coat toast you can put all
four flavors in one you know what i was
thinking that like since we launched
sprints i really sprint spritz i really
haven't drank anything else and then
when i went to the wedding i was just
like drinking so much tequila and i was
really thinking like i wish i had a
spritz that's so great i know just you
guys should have brought some with you
just some vertical integration code
toastedsportssociety.com
society.com code toast so other than
that my weekend was
quiet lovely you watched he's all that
and i didn't so don't spoil it but tell
me how it was i watched he's all that
friday morning as i promised like i saw
it was out addie was posting about it
and i was you didn't watch it at 12 p.m
pacific time no because i um i was
sleeping because i'm pregnant yeah so i
woke up sweet are you pregnant
yeah i'm pregnant um so i woke up and i
was like bro we've got to see our girl
dude
so we watched it and it was
fantastic really she is a star i heard
like you know people love to drag tick
tock stars specifically addison like
whenever they do something in a new
field like when she released a song like
attitude i actually have heard amazing
things i haven't read like any reviews
or seen any comments really i only
talked to snitch about it she also
really liked it but like
i loved it she first of all she's a
really good actress and like because she
was playing like you know an influencer
oh she was that's yeah that's the point
of the she's like the popular girl who
these days is an influencer so true and
she like does her all her stuff but like
she just had such
good energy and she was such a great
actress and i really was believing all
of it and even like the
the geek that they took from like zero
to hero like before he really was being
like a
a geek and it was believable yeah and
then he wasn't just like a nerd who
takes off his glasses and everybody
realizes he's handsome no he took off
his beanie and everybody's like
no and then after he really was so
handsome so i was just like i felt like
the writing was there okay kardashian
has a huge part oh no way just like i
thought addison like stops over at her
friend's house and like talks about what
happened i saw things on tic tacs so i
thought they had one phone call no
she's like a big i mean i don't want to
overstate it but like i thought she was
in it for two seconds a cameo she's in
it multiple times well you know who is
in it as a cameo and doesn't even have a
line you probably didn't even notice
it's bryce hall wasn't it no i didn't
know so there's a scene i don't know who
anyone is i just thought they're like
maybe at like a party or a bryce who's
her ex-boyfriend oh okay but he was in
it because they were dating at the time
i don't know but like he's like one of
the friends in like this jock group and
he's like bro took a picture of me and
he's just like taking a picture of this
guy went over my head sorry i was just
watching the movie at face value my only
critique of the movie
the wardrobe department owes madison an
apology okay it was as you like to say
turned turn her prom dress
horrific
horrific the dress she's wearing in the
opening scene that's like that i guess
like fake missoni dress with like the
big clogs wedges
like
it was atrocious that sucks because
she's like so fun and young and
beautiful like it would have been a
great you know there were some moments
where she just like totally fine she was
on a cardigan and shorts like a little
mini skirt when she was at the pool
party oh my god 10 out of 10 on the look
but i just feel like someone in there
was trying to sabotage her it was like a
missed opportunity too yeah and it was
just like taking away from the story
line like oh my god i'm so glad that
it's going over well i feel like i just
love addison ray so much and i just like
i wish that i was like you know 11 years
old and like being influenced i think i
would have like such a healthy like
look on life if like addison ray was my
role model i was saying to snitch i said
the campers are obsessed with addison
there's going to be pictures of her all
over the bunk this summer no and i just
love that she's getting like so famous
and she hasn't like really of course she
wears makeup and like does fun things
with her hair she hasn't like gone crazy
and like gone on crazy diets she looks
so normal like she's such a normal body
like i just love her and like i
literally will not stand for a morsel of
addison ricelander like you come here
slandering addison rey's good [ __ ]
name
shame on you she brought everything she
had to the movie oh i'm so excited it
was so good it's a real treat and so i
watched it that morning and then zach
and i we went away for the weekend we
took a little road trip and then oh yeah
i forgot
it was really nice and then olivia and
zach wound up coming too um and miss k
of course
and that the first night we were there
was just me and zach and we were like
trying to figure out what to watch and i
was like you could watch cheese all that
we started it i almost watched it twice
in one day by the way then i was like i
actually can't watch this two times in
one day it was it was like it was too
much when you guys were out in the
boonies
together alone were you scared in a
house petrified okay that's a crazy
thing to do like not stay in a hotel i
am someone
who is like pretty easily spooked about
stuff like that yeah like kidnapping
yeah and
i lost sleep
but then when olivia k and zach came
like if i lived in a house permanently
with zak shapiro i wouldn't be scared of
anything yeah no it definitely you know
having the numbers definitely helped um
but it was it was a brave thing to do
that's crazy it was really crazy like it
was crazy um i finished eliza starts a
rumor the book you recommended and i
have to say i just adored it like it
really lived up to the expectations and
honestly when i first started reading it
it was longer than i expected and i just
hate long books but it really breezed
right by i read it like on the plane
there on the plane back and then i
finished it when i got home it was just
delightful and you know it did take a
turn
that i didn't expect um because it was
pretty much like a light
story the whole time and then there's
kind of like a heavy element at the end
but i just loved it like it got usually
with books no matter on the lanes like
even if i'm loving it by the end i'm
like
okay wrap it up like let's go and by the
end here i was just like it couldn't it
like ended too quickly yeah so i gave it
four out of five stars but i was like
teetering on five i'm not gonna lie it
was really good i highly recommend you
know i do think maybe um trigger warning
for the book they do talk about sexual
assault and rape but um
it was a really good book i don't
remember you don't it's like the whole
thing in the book
i'll tell you afterwards remind me um i
love that book as well i read it this
time last year so i'm glad that you
finally read it i actually i started a
book this weekend called empty mansions
which is like a true crazy story about
like an american family um
and then i realized we're recording the
redheads on wednesday so i had to read
the redheads book which so i started it
yesterday and finished it yesterday it
was really good it's called cinch's
choice yes snitch's choice it's called
we are the brennans and it's great well
i like it
i think that you would i do think that
you would okay it was really really good
i i told like i mean i couldn't put it
down yesterday and that took up my whole
day and now i have like two free days
till we record so i guess i'll go back
to my other book that i was in the
middle of how can you do that like i've
never done that but usually i don't like
to do it i do the last thing in your
brain right i don't like to cross wire
so like maybe i just won't read until
wednesday
but it was really great so
i would say it's a great time to become
a redhead i would say it
that's a crazy thing to say it's a crazy
thing to say but i was crazy i would say
like this is a great book to start with
i think a lot like most people will like
it i'm sure i think i'll be shocked if
not all four of us liked it oh i guess
we'll have to wait and see until the
girls are back together but the girls
you know they love to disagree um
we also do your toasters today and we
have an update
exciting do you remember the girl who
like you know was in a relationship and
things were going well and she like at
the same time she had went to nashville
and met this guy and like they never
really like whatever but he would like
been texting her and asked her for feed
pics and he was not going to pay her for
them okay she gave us an update i hope
she gave him the picks and made a little
cash money times are tough times in this
economy sell your feed
100 become an entrepreneur work for
yourself if you love what you do and
your feet are stunning you'll never work
a day in your life so true my feet are
the opposite of stunning i need is there
some sort of plastic surgery for like
big fat feet my feet aren't cute either
they're like
loads of bread that's how i like to just
describe mine mine are a little bit like
baked bread mine are leavened for sure
[Laughter]
um should we dive in i guess we should
ivan because we actually have some good
stuff to talk about so without further a
do i won't offend anyone today it's
early in the week i'll wait till
tomorrow yeah you're really triggering
people i know here are the five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
claudia being offended is a just a
consequence of leaving your house in the
morning i love that quote me too um
today's episode is brought to you by our
patreon what is patreon you ask it is
our subscription service so this show
five days a week some days four sundays
three is totally free and it always will
be
we'll see um but we offer a subscription
service for 7.99 every month you can get
five extra episodes from us their
podcasts their vlogs we have special
guests family members lots of pregnancy
content that's where jackie's pregnancy
vlog and pregnancy q a was and probably
where most of your pregnancy content
will be for the next how many months
i can never remember seven because it's
like lucky ten months right yeah
six and a half seconds
um so that's
patreon.com 7.99 cents gets you those
five episodes and it also gets you
access to our last remaining facebook
group with all the other patreon members
the toast after dark so it's a great way
to get more content and support your
gals patreon.com the morning toast thank
you so much okay first story the big
story of the weekend i would say was
taking place in venice
oh you know i would actually describe
not that it's a competition
the biggest story of the weekend was
probably donda oh really that's just
what i perceived when i was in tully
right but maybe things in totally rad
were different than they were for you in
new york that's true i mean i did listen
to donda and
we could talk about it oh is it not a
story it wasn't gonna be a story because
like okay donna dropped donna dropped it
like it's the second biggest album drop
in streaming ever it did surpass
folklore which like obviously everyone
was like and losing their minds over um
and for me like the one really just a
small reason i wanted to talk about it
was because i did listen to it it's very
good i'm not gonna like i'm not gonna
lie and sit here and pretend like i
understood everything like some of the
beats like i it went over my head but
like that's what kanye does he creates
beats that you've never heard before and
then like
in a few years you'll be like how did
that be not exist before that right so
i'm not gonna you know i didn't
understand it all but i appreciated and
respected the art of it all but i just
do really feel like i'm so glad that the
album finally dropped and like was a
huge success because i just feel like at
this point
in a lot of ways when it comes like
kanye and his music and he's always late
like
some people like regard him as like a
joke and i just honestly i feel like he
needed to win and this was a huge win
that's all i'm saying i think the
narrative around kanye is really
interesting because it's like yes the
media
and the critics like
really consider him a joke they write
about him like he's you know crazy right
but the fans and the people likely and
like it's always like this like numbers
like you've never seen before like he
could fill stadiums like nobody else can
like decides one the next day we're
gonna do a listening party and it so
it's like the
you know
what's being said about him doesn't
represent how people actually feel also
i did see that his two listening parties
at those two stadiums grossed 12 million
dollars seven million in sales and then
the rest in merch so he literally made
just as much money in merch as he did
ticket sales right so if you like just
read the like headlines in life you
would just think like connie was just
like this bro crazy man yeah
but that's not the reality no so like i
was just really glad to see him win
and kim win and she wore the dress he
stays winning everything he touches
turns
to gold what did you think about the
wedding dress of it all at the oh my
gosh okay yeah you're playing with us i
guess that's um
that's newsworthy i agree okay first
story donna here we
go yeah something's gotta go so you have
the second bit elizabeth holmes you can
wait till tomorrow what's she up to her
trial started for theranose we'll talk
about it tomorrow i have to i can't even
lie like i never watch a documentary i
have no idea who lives with homes
because i just know she wears
turtlenecks and she has a man voice and
she's like this
okay
um so donda
second album listening party kim
participated they built the house he had
the baby and marilyn manson which people
were like up in arms about which i feel
that um but kim came out in a valencia
wedding dress and i'm not sure what it
meant i'm not sure okay i i'm not sure
what it meant either
but for me it's it's could only be good
like first even if they're obviously i
don't think they're back together like
i'm not
that
delusional foolish but even though they
are literally standing there as man and
wife but yeah i'm the crazy one
i don't think they're back together but
like they're clearly on such good terms
the fact that she would participate like
in his art in this way right and that i
feel like i feel like what could happen
i feel like in their marriage they
really just became like not even
roommates because they weren't living
together they were like pen pals across
the country and like i'm sure kim was
like i want love like i want romance i
want to be swept off my feet and i feel
like
they're going to take this time away
from each other to go do those things
and make sure maybe she'll go find maybe
she's already you know had some
flings and things
but i think they're going to come back
to each other because nobody is
right for either on par with either like
yeah so even if or maybe they'll come i
don't know i just i think it all really
bodes well for the ship and the family
and i think whatever arrangement though
they have or they will have in the
future like it will be unconventional
but like you can't break these two no
and honestly like we i i don't know how
you felt but like when i saw her at the
first listening party wearing like a
matching outfit i'm like oh my god she's
there and she's wearing an outfit like
my bar was so low and now it's like
she's a bride you know like we're moving
in a good direction we're moving in a
really good direction so it's all i feel
really okay with where things are me too
and maybe they're each on the side like
getting what they need but the family
unit it just can't be broken no i cannot
they have such a strong bond with their
kids and um i'm really rooting for them
i really am too so the album i listened
to most of it my favorite song is jail
but it's also because it's at the top of
the album so every time i start the
album i listen to it totally no but it's
also that good and jay-z's verse is very
good and i just love seeing you know
brother and brother back together again
like two brothers yes and then also on
first listen i also like the song
hurricane yes with the weekend right
yeah you know what's weird is that all
these people are featured on it but he
didn't give credit no i'm sure they have
the credit on the back end but in the
title
in the album featuring was interesting
too but it's like how well do you know
your favorite artist right so uh there
was a bunch of rappers who i couldn't
like
tell who was who but obviously jay-z's
voice he's so famous and the weeknd
style is very unique um
but i was like why is it in the title
yeah no that was confusing
but i don't know but then also kanye put
out that universal drop the record like
without his approval like it wasn't
ready still and he's not happy
got it
well i i enjoyed it i really only got
through half of it every song is three
years long um
but it's a journey and i'm
willingly going down and taking that
journey yeah me too it's going to take
some time to get through the entire
journey but it's always fun to have a
journey to even go on in the first place
that's true so happy for the whole west
family and also some other like news was
that kim posted like some songs on her
stories and then like the volume was all
the way down oh my god on the screen
shots okay i just have to say like
literally
every morning i take a screenshot of the
chose podcast and put it up like swipe
up i haven't listened to it i lived it
first of all and second of all like i'm
not listening to it i'm promoting it
like right it's if you look at it first
of all the volume's down and it's at
zero seconds like i haven't even started
it yet no i totally agree so can
honestly can she live had an audio
business and you knew what it was like
to run an audio business you would
know what it's like but you don't that's
not a big deal at all she's obviously
promoting kanye's music but she has to
listen to the whole song before she's
allowed to promote it i'm sure she's
heard it a million times i agree i had
no time for it but i'm glad you agree
can she live
no don't you know she can't live
honestly that whole can i live thing
where she cut north out of a picture
because she liked the way that she
looked and like north didn't that will
forever be one of my favorite kim
moments such good times when like
literally north space is like sliced in
half
that was good north okay now for i guess
the second big story of the weekend i'm
gonna blow my nose while you talk oh
okay
that's good
venice italy dolce gabbana alta moda
show courtney and travis pack on the pda
plus a lot more
celeb sightings i was living for their
italy content first of all people were
saying that
they took that trip to cabo as a test
run for him flying because they went to
italy you should fly to italy i didn't
even think of that right unless they're
taking a ship but i don't think it takes
two weeks yeah but actually i think
they've been on like a yacht so it's
possible but no i'm sure i think they
flew i'm sure that they just flew um
they're literally hot and heavy in italy
like the fashion show looked amazing and
like it really did and the setting was
beautiful but like everybody's stories
were like courtney and travis are in the
front row and so you can like see them
being like so loved up it was just there
was so much to see courtney loves a pda
in italy moment it's worth mentioning
that this is not the first time she has
had some scandalized photos come out
from italy do you remember her and
eunice on the boat where she's like
she's reaching under the boat to like
grab something and like literally hold
our asses out do you remember that no
okay so she just loves it uh
uh italy you know pda moment yes but
also i think she just like loves she
seems like the type that when she goes
on vacation like she's
thoroughly vacating like not worrying
about the paparazzi so
but they're also like we're posting
really cute pictures there was like some
sunglass swapping these like prada
frames very cute
i was obviously following the whole
weekend through simon because like he
takes the best content on his instagram
simon chris and corey were there did you
see the story that chris and corey are
getting married they better like
honestly on my way over here i was
getting myself so worked up because like
the first thing that happened when i
opened my phone this morning was a
carousel of photos of corey gamble
smoking a cigar in like four different
photos of the same thing and i was just
like justice for this man like him and
chris literally
relationship goals they seem so happy so
like healthy not toxic like i just
[ __ ] stand and i don't even need them
to get married you know what like
everything is perfect don't ruin it i
love this man and i love these two
together i love them so much i agree i
don't need them to get married it didn't
really cross my mind before because also
like none of the girls really are
married are married or getting married
she's like half
yeah she's only one she's the only one
so i don't need them to but i agree like
just chris and corey appreciation moment
they're everything chris and cory is one
of my favorite follows on instagram
same and like i just i can't really put
into words how i feel about corey gamble
i think he's so gorgeous like his face i
don't want to look
so cute i love him second of all i think
he's such a you know it takes a very
strong man
to stand behind a powerful woman
and he is just there supporting support
support what can i do who can i help who
can i take in the car he is just not
gentle
he is just a dream man i'm sorry like i
love him and i think that honestly like
it's the healthiest relationship i've
seen in pop culture i'm serious no i
completely agree and when they announced
it we were all like who what what
and if you had told me what has it been
now like six years like
right
um
i don't know whatever if you had told me
then that like chris and corey would be
not only like the powers of power
couples but like the most healthy
kardashian relationship like i would
have laughed in your face yeah and here
i am standing corrected standing
corrected i agree so it's a pleasure
just to see them
living life it's a pleasure
i'm living life what's
courtney what does she say
i'm just living life it's a tick tock
sound yeah and also there's a tick tock
sound that i've been loving and i just
found out what it's from and you're
gonna love it okay say it's me first let
me see if i can find out someone kill me
please kill me i'm asking y'all i'm
begging not asking locked in a cage with
all the rats that's slipped under their
cracks
oh cameron diaz and annie yes oh my god
okay so i just found out what that sound
was from and i've just been like every
time i'm walking around the city i'm
like locked in a cage with all the rats
and i didn't realize it's crazy when you
like know something from tick tock and
then you see it out in the real world
and it's mind-blowing and then i just
found out it was cameron diaz as ms
hannigan i'm so but you want to know
what gave it away like the way you said
someone kill me please kill me you
sounded like her no cause
someone kill me please tell me i'm
begging not asking locked in a cage with
all their access to their cracks oh my
god queen i'm so glad annie is having
it's come up inside oh tick-tock and by
the way we never even spoke about how
annie was cast
yes they cast annie she they did an open
casting for annie live and they found
their annie and i'm so excited she's
adored it's all it's all happening it's
all happening even though like we're
like so jazzed about annie and like when
we were with
when we were with our sisters like we
were talking about annie they're like
why are you guys so excited we're like
we're like listen to this guy and we're
like you obviously don't listen to the
shows right so we're just like listen to
the cast and we're rattling it off and
like as we're going down we're like
this sounds like a terrible cast like
we we've just been getting like small
bits of information and we announced
each bit on the show but i don't think
we've really ever looked at the cast at
a glance so here's here's what we have
so far we have annie who is an unknown
child
but she won out of all the other annie
so i'm sure she's super talented i have
no no concerns
taraji taraji p henson as miss hannigan
how are you junior as daddy warbucks and
like
i guess i don't know i have to say i
still stand by that
casting but i think where things go
south is number four nicole scherzinger
as grace and i said that when we
announced it and you said it was good
and then when we told the sisters like
that was the turning point i'm just
trying to be upbeat and then you do have
titus as rooster but as you said
everything that titus has been in since
kimmy schmidt like
it's not great he's
he was too good at playing titus
andromedon that like
you he's actually incapable in my mind
uh for me at least to perceive him as
anything other than oh titus is an annie
like you know what i mean it's like oh
he left kimmy schmidt to go be in a
production of annie like
i can't get my head out of the like the
space that he's tied his andromeda yeah
i would agree with that so i'm just
trying to remain optimistic but i did
have a moment of like clarity and a lot
of clarity when we were explaining it
they were like why are you guys so
excited we're like listen are you going
and then
the more we went on their faces were
like
what and i i kind of feel it i'm not
gonna lie but let's remain sure yeah she
was a dark point let's just remain
positive and save our negativity for
after for the reviews okay now for part
two of um the courtney and travis pday
story
eunice decided to let us know eunice who
is courtney's ex who they dated for a
long time not never really like publicly
he was never on the show i don't think
anybody liked him
um he shared a dm that he received from
scott disick that had a photo of the pda
in italy and said yo is this chick okay
bro
like what is this in the middle of italy
and then eunice replied saying it
doesn't matter to me as long as she's
happy p.s i ain't your bro so i think we
should unpack this really from the
beginning step by step before we get
into it and then eunice put a caption on
top of that saying keep the same energy
you had about me publicly privately
so
i have to say i'm definitely biased
because
from what i know about eunice they
referred him on the show they never say
his name but they're always referring to
like one of courtney's exes who was the
worst
and after i remember after they broke up
he was like leaving comments he's like
very weird about courtney showing her
body and like thinks that like she's
sexualizing and demeaning herself like
it's literally 1940. and then um there
was that video that came out of him
after him and courtney broke up with
like literally beating the life out of
someone who worked at the nice guy in
l.a so from what i know about eunice it
ain't good yeah so
do i think this screenshot is real i i
can't
i can't imagine that it's fake
but he also can't understand why scott
would reach out to this person he's like
irrelevant now okay never cross my mind
that the screenshot might not be real
i'm gonna
no i'm saying i think it's real i think
it's real
i think courtney and scott must be in
such a bad place if he's going to eunice
who clearly did not end the relationship
with courtney on good terms and they
were only ever dating they weren't like
friends before or friends after so like
he's not a part like usually in the
family even when you date someone and
you break up like there's still a part
of the circle french
to say eunice is not a part of the
circle i think the fact that scott would
reach out to him is such a big trail
yeah of the family and i think that like
if this is all real which i think it is
like
he'll be feeling the heat after this
yeah no it's not good it's like
so that's great like this whole thing is
so crazy to me that he would reach out
to eunice and like try and commiserate
with him and it's also like scott where
do you get off like you literally post
pictures of your 18 year old
girlfriend's
vagina no
the hypocrisy is so real but also the
reason like this makes no sense but then
when you unpack it like
eunice's thing always and i think what
they always argued about was like
courtney loves showing off her body and
she's very proud of her body and like
courtney thinks i mean i think eunice
like wanted her to be more modest and so
i could see scott
being upset about this and eunice is the
perfect person to go to because he used
to hate when she would go on instagram
and like show her ass and like get
paparazzi in a bikini so i actually see
scott's line of thinking here in
choosing eunice i think there's no
thought here and i think it's clear that
scott is in a bad place because only
someone who's like really not thinking
clearly would think that that is a good
idea
and that makes me savor him because i
feel like for so long he's been in a
good place like bring back sophia
no this is i think i'm
this is bad it's bad and i think
obviously like the betrayal is bad
because like the kardashians are like
like literally like they're like the mob
family family it's literally the only
thing that matters you never betrayed
the family never go against the family
scott is in the family right and they
never even at his worst all the mistakes
he made they never turn their backs on
him ever they have protected him they've
given him a life and for him to betray
them first of all is so upsetting and
two
the blatant hypocrisy of this all of all
of this is so
blatant yeah like you have a girlfriend
who like literally what was it like two
weeks ago that picture of her like
reaching up on a bookshelf where you
could literally see her butthole like
right that's what i'm saying so you did
that you constantly taking pictures of
her like really inappropriate she's also
so young right
hello pot kettle you're black right also
like just want to say the picture that
he sent to eunice was a paparazzi photo
so she's just like living her life
she's not in control of it she's
literally just living life again versus
the pictures that scott posts that
nobody asked he takes he posts he puts
it out it's his content
you can't
can you control what the paparazzi
captures you shouldn't live differently
because you're worried about what people
are gonna see i'm so team courtney on
this it's disgusting disgusting and this
is now like the series
i feel like everything we've reported
about scott in the last few months like
hasn't been good and we also don't even
report about him that much because like
we just don't want to give any life to
his inappropriate relationships still
inappropriate will always be
inappropriate especially because it's a
pattern for him and that's just really
[ __ ] concerning um and still like we
should all be concerned about it yeah no
and i think like honestly the way we see
it portrayed on real housewives of
beverly hills is actually even more
concerning because like lisa
like scott is obviously like a powerful
person he's older and like amelia
and lisa is just like like loving it
like you should be protecting your
daughter not like relishing in the fame
right but also i think it would maybe be
different if scott like had been in a
relationship with courtney
and say his next relationship was with
amelia okay maybe these two like met and
found fell in love but the fact that
like every single person he's been with
since is like just become legal
borderline minor
yeah it's twisted it's disgusting yeah
and honestly like i i really wish andy
cohen had pressed him more at the
reunion i don't you know look for them
the young girls find me like no they
don't no they don't you're an older
you're showing up in the kindergarten no
literally like cradle robbing everywhere
you go stop it yeah stop blaming the
younger women so what i was just wanting
to say is i think scott is like in a bad
place scott
bps bps that's what i'm sensing and then
um i mean
i i can believe that eunice shared this
to his instagram especially because his
response comes off so well you just such
a [ __ ] starter i just want him to be
happy liar
no but like if he knew he was posting it
he could say you know and yeah right
like he if if it's private he would be
like yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] like
no i'm sure he saw it like knew he was
gonna post and so he wrote back
something nice he could also be like let
me be the hero i'm also working on
curing cancer right too busy for this
gotta head out of my habitat for
humanity trip no he's painting himself
as the hero of course yeah but like
scott gave him that opportunity scott's
a [ __ ] yeah so that was really crazy i
woke up to so many messages people
sending me
eunice's story i was like the [ __ ] did
you just do that i'm
seeing so many stories yeah but see like
so much if it doesn't make sense first
of all it was their first message if you
look at it it's like there's no messages
above so they don't talk like it so much
of it makes no sense
but when you think about the fact that
scott's probably in a very bad place
right now
he would do something quite erratic yeah
honestly i've this is one of the
situations where i wish the show was on
yeah filming i don't know if they are
i'm so confused about what's going on
with hulu we have no information we have
no information but i think this is a
betrayal
you
betrayed me
and i know that you'll never feel sorry
[Music]
but you know what i feel like courtney
like might not have even seen this yet
like she's so busy being in love and you
know
gallivanting around europe like
sorry she's busy this will have to take
a backseat yeah she's on positano time
yeah
like that the food looks so good
everything i'm just starving everything
like give me a dolce dress and some
pasta primavera i don't even need the
dress just the pasta i know but the
fashion show was amazing yeah i think
the fashions and they it was really like
a star wars things next time you need a
dress
okay that was only oh that was our
second story hold on oh my god let me
give elizabeth homes the boot quickly
okay next story some really exciting
book to movie oh my god i'm so excited
neila kunis is spotted in new york city
shooting scenes for
luckiest girl alive sorry don't make fun
of me i just was like moving words in
the headline around i wasn't planning on
it to make it make more sense
pregnancy brain luckiest girl alive is
filming mila kunis was spotted in the
streets one picture in a baby blue dress
like looking so stunning we also saw the
other pictures of her kissing the man
who's probably placed her boyfriend
who's the like an [ __ ] and yeah he
like
he's a complex character no he's a prick
yeah he like never let her talk about
her trauma yeah he hit the picture and
he was like one of those douchebags like
yeah but it took her a while to see
right that like he's probably one of the
well let's not spoil him okay sorry
sorry but he looks the guy who's cast is
like perfect the guy whose cast is
perfect he's from the big short um
and i'm pretty sure he's the guy who
came up with the iconic line one plus
one equals sock
because
that's from the big short i don't know
if that's exactly what he said but i
remember the first time i said it was
because i just watched big short got it
so
i think he's perfect me too he looks
like you know who i thought would be
good for it too who i cannot remember
his name but the guy from something
borrowed
yeah
yeah but that movie's just like a little
old
social media yes we might be like he
might be old but that's exactly that's
what i was reading the book that's why i
was picturing as her boyfriend yeah what
i think is connor i think the casting is
on point and then it actually took me
into um
the imdb for luckiest girl live to see
who else is in the movie because i was
like oh if they got that so right i look
forward to seeing because i want to see
who plays young mila kunis okay but by
the way i swear on my life i would never
be one of these people and i hate myself
for even what i'm about to say
but before you
see the movie read the book it's really
good the book is so good you guys like
it's the best book i read it in 2020 so
it was my best book of 2020. yeah it's
so amazing it's just stunning and it's
long and i didn't even mind it was
really long okay so i wanted to see who
was playing like young male penis
because i thought it should have been
the girl from that movie let it snow um
you know that movie
on when i show you a picture of this
girl
you're gonna she looks like everyone
said she looks like mila kunis at the
time okay but she didn't get the role is
what you're saying no she didn't get the
role but the person that in the picture
who did get the role does look what's
her name like her her name is
sorry i have so many tabs open kiara
aurelia i'm just assuming based on her
picture got it and who oh who's connie
britton connie britton's in the movie
maybe she's um
ani's mom i don't know
oh my god connie britain's in the movie
and jennifer beals is in it they're not
saying who's who
no when i looked last time there wasn't
saying it just said cast but not
super written this movie's gonna be so
[ __ ] good but when they had all these
like younger kids for the high school
they literally look exactly look at
these kids pictures they look exactly
like what you would think like that
girls yeah that's obviously dean one of
them liam the crew who plays
i don't want to spoil it guys it's so
good oh but i love how like nobody has
billing like it's just connie britain's
in the movie but the woman in airport is
played by
a lala panker like that's the only
person who has like a a role
that's funny that's really funny so i'm
so jazzed about this so [ __ ] jazz and
i guess this guy scott mcnair is the
teacher
okay when i was picturing the teacher it
was jason street from friday night live
oh yeah you told me that that was really
good and honestly i do think he should
have been cast but whatever like i'm so
excited about this i don't think i've
ever been like one of those people who's
like really read the book and seen the
movie like i've never and when people
are like i read the book it was so much
better i'm like yeah i'm sure sally like
but you know what sally was on to
something because i'm sure this movie is
going to be great but the book was so
powerful
and i it will be so difficult for the
movie to be better than the book because
the book is a masterpiece yeah but
honestly i'm so pleased with what what
i've seen so far yeah her blue dress
like she looks stunning she works in a
magazine she's like a fabulous girl yeah
and honestly she's giving me any vibes
now when it first came out i could
totally see her being annie but when i
was reading the book and then i thought
about the movie i wanted to be emma
roberts because she was like the exact
age of bonnie and i think she had a
funny dark sense of humor the only thing
is that the
mila kunis is much older than the
character but mila kunis has this like
ageless effervescence so i think we'll
be fine so like why can't ani be in her
30s like she just happened to be 20 in
the book but like okay so everything was
maybe it was the 10-year anniversary or
yeah
anniversary whatever that i can work
with it's so good like i'm so excited so
excited okay next story are you ready
yeah
the view has lined up a bunch of guest
co-hosts to fill megan mccain's role
there
there's not a ro a person who's filling
the role yet but they have some guest
stars who i guess will be like
auditioning probably like jeopardy style
yeah i guess you can't just like give
the i mean i don't know how people
usually i never keep up with the view
like
in the past how have people gotten cast
i wonder if it's been like they have a
bunch of guests or if there was someone
who like came on as a guest a lot of
times and then they were like people
really liked her and now there's an
opening that's what i thought it was
going to be on a navarro like who was
always filling in right but i mean maybe
it will still wind up being her but they
have a bunch of different people lined
up some pop culture names who
andy
andy cohen
it has to be a female oh right sorry
okay so
first former utah representative mia
love will join the stars when the show
resumes on september 7th and then other
figures who are set to come on the show
include condoleezza rice gretchen
carlson ebony k williams
shut up mary katherine hamm carly
fiorina alyssa farah cameron eubanks
what
an essie cup who you know from what's up
and i think a lot of people just assumed
essie cup would get it and that she
would be perfect because she's from cnn
friends with megan yeah um
but now i'm like really interested wait
i'm sorry we have got to back pedal yeah
okay
ebony's everything obviously but she's a
political commentator like yeah
honestly wendy could be on this too from
potomac but she's live in new york like
that's not shocking they work in
politics
cameron eubanks is southern charm
correct she's a mother she wrote the
book on mother's yep
yep that's unless there's two camera new
banks who spend spell their names
exactly there has to be two
but cameron with r-a-n i don't get it
make it make sense but why should you do
politics
i don't know maybe she will like i'm
sure she has opinions and
she was a really great like narrator on
the show she's well spoken she's funny
and maybe maybe she's not gonna but
maybe she's not even in the running to
take the seat but she's gonna guest host
an episode
i'm sorry i don't i really don't
understand i'm having a hard time like
ingesting that information yeah i really
feel like this is gonna be mean and it's
not a slight towards cameron at all i
love her like i do
but i just feel like the view has
remained this place where like
you have to work in politics like do you
know what i mean like
yeah but why can't you be someone who
came up a different way but and maybe
she has like interesting political
and i'm sure she wouldn't
you know
raise her hand for this position if she
doesn't think she could hack it yeah i'm
just like actually i don't know if i'll
watch it actually i have it recorded so
i whenever she's on i'll check it out i
like i really do like like and
appreciate the view so like i just want
the integrity too
and i think that
ebony has already been on the view as a
guest you know i love the crossover but
this that's like a logical thing she's a
political talking head that's literally
what she does for a living and she's a
lawyer like it makes total sense um
so i was like excited to hear her name
but i wasn't confused like i am with
cameron
but um i love a bravo moment crossover
and honestly like ebony would be great
that would just be crazy like because i
feel like garcelle really got
her job on the talk due in large part to
like her success on the housewives like
people loved her that would just be
crazy if like let's say ebony got the
job at the view like and housewives of
course has something to do with that
like that would just be like crazy like
bravo just like taking over day time
that would be crazy i mean same with
cameron not that i think she's even in
the running for the job like definitely
had her own show like it was just like
just crazy yeah so still keeping an eye
on who is going to get that seat but
this is like feels like jeopardy style
and then maybe like the executive
producer in the end will get it right
and then the executive producer has all
tweets yeah exactly okay that is
interesting i figured that they had like
would just fill the spot immediately and
like move on yeah no i'm sure but i'm
also sure this is good for ratings to
like milk it a little bit and like make
it like a little bit of a rat race and
see who brings in ratings like yeah some
like cameron eubanks might get amazing
ratings or terrible people love her
so and i i think it could be interesting
me too that would just be crazy like
the same girl
who you know co-hosts of you like she
was on the real world right right and
like she like knows thomas ravenel you
know what i mean no so she's into
politics she has an inside trailer yeah
that's true i forgot about the thomas
ravenel of it all he was a former
congressman and then a failed attempt at
a second senator i think and then um
tried to do it again
yeah then he went to jail and then he
tried to run again got it that was a
really good idea yeah
okay ready for our fifth and final story
a little like new romance news
is it oh
[ __ ]
the final story
[Music]
stunning yes it is yes it is
and so it's a little rumor dating news
that i found interesting kristen
cavallari is allegedly according to e
news dating the singer chase rice inside
their new romance yeah i read that on
jamaa actually okay then that actually
gives it a little bit more yes i like
how everyone just heals from duma
basically someone wrote into mom was
like i was at a restaurant oh
no
yeah they were at a restaurant or
something like on the bahamas or
something and they overheard chase rice
talking to his friends about how he's
been seeing kristen cavallari and like
honestly it's getting kind of serious
and he's like really into her
and she was like please keep it low-key
i think she was at baker's bay she was
like it's a member's only club like do
not snitch on me kristen was there chase
rice and the person who wrote into juan
was there too over eavesdropping got it
got it okay well it's literal here
hearsay it is but
the laguna beach alum and the singer are
dating enus can confirm according to a
source the stars who both reside in the
nashville area have been spending time
together for a little over a month at
the moment it's still casual it's new
the insider tells e news she's been to
one of his shows already and they're
having fun i love fun no i mean
literally every year we talk to chase
rice on the red carpet we're always
trying to set him up with someone and he
did better than we ever could yeah we
were trying to set him up with like
people from the bachelor like he's
obviously better than that um
and i love this i really think it's a
great pairing me too like it's i'm so
excited i mean kristen cavallari must
she's really the perfect like person to
be single it's just like she's the most
eligible bachelor she lives in nashville
she's and she's so stunning and she has
such a great personality so it's like
you know of course your looks can get
you through the door but then you have
to talk to someone for like a lifetime
yeah how's that going no it must be fun
to be chris and cavallari and be single
in nashville like jealous of all the fun
she's having yes like i don't think she
gets rejected you know yes
chase rice is hot she does the rejecting
yeah
and that was just crazy that victoria
fuller and kristen cavallari have like
kiss the same boy have cross swords
literally um
i guess she's not dating austin or craig
either oh yeah i didn't really think
that they were yeah i'm also confused
like what's going on with craig with
paige yeah because also like you know
naomi's single
she is and i'm sorry i do think that
naomi and craig like are soul mates i do
i don't so i think their relationship
would take a lot of work
but
i don't think they're soulmates actually
i don't i would love to see them get
back together but like i don't know i
feel like craig's in this amazing spot
like yeah that's right and i do really
feel like naomi helped get him there
like maybe feel like say she was harsh
but like she kind of gave him the kick
in the ass that she needed yeah if if
she hadn't left he wouldn't be the
success that he is he needed to like
really hit rock bottom because you sit
at home and you sew
and you know it wasn't even about the
sewing it was the fact that he had no
ambition like no and like he was
depressed no you would see it on the
show like they would and he would like
say to like they would literally sleep
till like noon then like take adderall
go out come back be up till five sleep
till noon like that's just that's not a
life no like that's not a healthy
lifestyle and naomi wanna know part of
it but i guess for craig it's like now
that he's in such a good place it's like
well naomi didn't ride with him through
the lows um not that i not that i
disagree with her no i don't disagree
with her at all and i do think that like
she is definitely partially responsible
for getting him to this place yeah i
don't know i just think there's
something worth exploring there right
but it's it's like a revenge body sort
of thing it's like revenge life but then
you don't do it like but they they're on
good terms like i know that they are
okay i mean i totally [ __ ] but i just
don't think
i don't think she'll go back there and i
think at this point he wouldn't either
because i think the way that he now
views it is like
she left me at my most
vulnerable vulnerable okay well we've
got your toasters today and we have a
update which i'm really excited about so
today's a segment from dear toasters is
brought to you by purple doesn't it seem
like the world is against us from
getting a good night's sleep this year i
mean the heat the back of the neck sweat
it's just impossible to stay peaceful
and stay asleep but when you have a
purple mattress you can sleep cool and
comfortable no matter what the world
throws at you that's because only purple
mattresses have the grid it's a unique
ventilated design that allows air to
flow through to help you sleep cool even
when it feels like a thousand degrees
and the grid is amazingly supportive for
your back and legs while cushioning your
shoulders neck and hips no matter how
you sleep unlock unlike memory foam
which remembers everything the grid
bounces back as you move and shift so
you never get that um stuck feeling you
do with memory foam the grid is fabulous
but also the pillows are everything of
the sort it's hard to find pillows that
really support and i do have like a lot
of neck problems because i'm constantly
carrying around these jugs so
i implore you to look at all the purple
products i think there's gonna be
something that you'll love um try your
purple mattress risk-free with free
shipping and returns and financing is
available too it's comfort reinvented
and right now you can get 10 off any
order of 200 or more go to purple.com
tmt and use the code tmt that's
purple.com tmt promo code tmt for 10
10 off any order of 200 or more
purple.com tmt promo code tmt terms
apply
all right dear toasters our advice
segment if you ever want to write in
email us deartoasters gmail.com we will
always keep it anonymous and if uh you
have written in and we've read your
prompt on air send us an update
first up good morning steens long time
listener here coming to you with a
situation that could use some steeny
advice so there's this guy i went to
elementary school with let's call him
maverick
i always thought he was cute and a nice
guy but we went to different high
schools and kind of lost touch he posted
an instagram photo recently and i was
reminded of how cute he was since then i
kept having this weird gut feeling to
message him would i be overly ambitious
to dm this guy that i haven't spoke to
or seen in like eight years how does one
even go about messaging a maverick i've
been thinking to wait till he posts an
instagram story and maybe send a sweet
response but he's not an avid instagram
story kind of guy help
that's cute i feel like a lot of people
you know have cycled through everyone
they know currently and are starting to
go into the the background archives the
archives
so
i feel like you could well sometimes if
you're on a dating app and you guys are
in the same city like you do wind up
matching with people who you went to
kindergarten with so like you could wait
for that or you could do you have his
number did you guys have cell phones
back then i just have to say i think
there's just one thing we need to
discuss like there is a very very small
remote possibility that he doesn't
remember who you are that's all i'm
saying do you remember everyone i went
to middle school with no just maverick
i think he does because okay but we also
went to a small middle school so like i
actually do remember everyone i meant
went to middle school but i'm just
saying let's keep that in the back of
our minds okay but i'm gonna that would
be really like
tragic if he didn't but if you have his
number and you i have everyone from
middle school's number like pretty much
you know if you don't get so many new
phones
um i think you could text him as and
have it be like an accidental text oh
that is so pretty you meant it for
someone else and you could just say
something like so random like
you know jackie that's the lamest [ __ ] i
don't know
it's just random enough and if you think
of like the right thing you say like
whatever the next test you were gonna
send to like your
best friend is like send it to him by
accident right so you have to make it
like oh my god i meant to send it to my
friend amanda yeah that's what i was
gonna say like it has to be believable
because the accidental text one of my
favorite stories to tell i'm not gonna
name my friend because i love her but
she used to do this thing in denver
telling the story yeah i know the story
she used to do this thing in middle
school like you know ichat was
everything and she would dmp like text
like boys like hey ooh sorry wrong
message you know and then you get the
conversation going right and then one
time and the last time she ever did this
she accidentally wrote in the same
breath you know like the same sentence
usually she would write hey enter oh
sorry wrong message enter she wrote hey
sorry wrong message
she never did it again so these types of
situations can be quite precarious well
only if like you're a 12 year old and
whose brain just didn't decide to work
that day
it's the best story but i think
i wonder if anyone's actually ever had
success with this because it's a pretty
good plan like it's random enough that
he doesn't think you've been like
crushing on him stalking him you'll send
him like a random [ __ ] text that's
like
i don't know just whatever text you were
gonna send to someone else just send it
to him that's like benign enough and
then be like oh my god i meant to send
this mary maverick
or
maybe have it be like a sexy like not a
sexy like a really cute picture of you
be like can you edit this for me no
that's so embarrassing oh is it okay
yeah sorry i've been out of the game for
a while um i think just something like
but there's also something earnest about
just being honest like hey math no
because you're on like because at the
end of the day this is like
you don't know him anymore so it's not
about like a sweet crush that you have
it's like you think he's looking good
and
you know you ran out of options
it's always nice to hear that you look
good
yeah i guess like if someone from middle
if i were single and someone from middle
school texted me like saying i was
looking good would i want to go out it
would be sweet like it's
the thing is it's like it never hurts to
hear someone's thinking of you or thinks
you're good looking yeah it's very sweet
yeah but like then how come it doesn't
work out more often because life sucks
okay i agree so i think you should reach
out you literally nothing to lose um
and go with whichever one of these
options you feel comfortable yeah but at
the end of the day it's gonna be the
same result like you're getting in front
on maverick's radar is he interested
good yeah all right next up jackie and
claudia i've always wanted to write into
your toasters and today i'm in dire need
of your advice i have a group of three
friends at work we've all been working
at the company for about a year we all
met at work the three other girls are a
lot closer
to each other than i am with them i'm
more of the keep our friendship in the
office type i've been out with them a
couple times but other than that i'm
never really invited i also never really
make an effort to hang out with them
either so it's not like it hurts my
feelings a few months ago we were all
invited to one of the girls bachelorette
party i don't know about the other two
girls but i am not in her wedding i was
hesitant to say yes but figured i would
take a chance and book the trip
now here i am a few weeks out and i feel
further away from them than ever i'm
really debating if i if i should even go
on this trip of course i if i don't i
would still help pay for my part of the
trip i wouldn't feel right if i didn't
but honestly i'm but honestly losing out
on that money sounds better than going
so i guess my question is should i suck
it up and go on the trip or am i
justified and feeling like i just
shouldn't be going if i don't go how do
i even approach telling them and what do
i say please help this conflict diverse
toaster out
i just go
well it depends where they're going does
it sound fun or are they like renting a
cabin in the woods they're like you're
paying for it just go like or are they
going to the bahamas are they going to
las vegas like if it's something where
like you can have a good time regardless
go but like if you're really just like a
bunch of girls sitting around in a house
that's true the trip is is an important
detail here yeah so if it's log cabin
vibes like no but if you don't want to
go and you're still going to pay and
like you don't really care what these
people like if they
you don't really care because this is
like your work relationships which by
the way i think that's a pretty healthy
mentality me too people who like
crossover like work wife all that [ __ ]
like it's so toxic yeah i agree
boundaries are important you could
there's so many excuses especially in
you know a pandemic
like cases are rising i can't make it
yeah there's excuses in a pandemic but
also like more excuses to party like
no no but she now wants to get out of it
so like she needed an excuse yeah i do
honestly i feel like 20 21 is a year of
just like doing things you want to do so
if you really don't want to go don't
torture yourself like i agree i feel
like that's what we learned in the
pandemic like i'm not spending my
weekends doing [ __ ] i don't want to do
anymore like
sorry agreed so i think i actually i'm
sorry i've had a change of heart like
you do what you want to do don't be an
[ __ ] so still pay
that's really nice but if you're not
even that close with them
i don't think they're gonna care yeah
just make up some excuse say you know
you're seeing your granny the the two
days later and so you can't like be
exposed yeah yeah yeah yeah like that so
always good with an exposure
yeah my favorite thing to do is like oh
sorry i can't come my dad died eight
years ago
all right
okay no
2008 13.
okay
all right next up is our final update so
you remember the girl met this guy in
nashville they hit it off um
then like they never really spoke and
you know a couple months later she has
boyfriend back at home and this guy's
texting her asking her for feed pics and
i do believe we told her not to like
invest in your relationship not in your
feed picks
hello my dearest claudia and jackie i
wanted to send you an update on my feed
pick predicament to refresh your memory
i wrote in saying that a hottie i met in
nashville several years ago randomly
asked me for feed picks but i had a
boyfriend so i was in a pickle long
story short i ended up dumping the
boyfriend a couple months later
unrelated to the feed pick situation
and earned about 200
honestly easiest money i've ever made
but i don't plan on pursuing this
endeavor further lol please find the
attached photo of my p precious gem feet
i feel as though it may spark joy best
regards now a rich toaster fork it over
i don't have it here i will um i'll
forward it to you oh is it in the email
it's an email just pull up your phone
i guess i have the same email but yeah
um but i'm really i love a great ending
i love a happy ending 200
that's beautiful like where are we going
what are we buying yeah um at the end of
the day
you made money and i don't know why you
would just you know cut yourself off
from doing it again sounds like it was
extremely prosperous is he a returning
customer or he got what he wanted and he
needs like one one hit and he's good
he's a one-hit wonder
okay i have two uh where it's like now
that your feet are old news
oh
you're like feet are crusty and he's not
interested no your feet aren't crusty
but like he's seen them you know there's
no more mystery right i'm trying to find
the email hold on it's okay we can find
it later i can look at your feet any
time of day no honestly i i really want
to find it i just i just got into the
email give me one second oh okay wow
here i have him
oh she didn't say
she didn't send a picture of her feet
she sent a picture of her dogs
she said her pee jobs i thought she was
referring to her feet let me see those
pidgeons they're cavaliers they're hella
cute it's a better picture they're
[ __ ] so cute oh that's something i
got two cabs these stunning i know
that's that's why she sent it now i
understand i thought she was sending um
no i didn't still want to see your feet
if you're yeah cause we gotta follow
another one i just wanna see what kind
of feet like you can make money on yeah
because it's not these it ain't these
loaves of bread honestly i don't know
they look like you have a spray tan and
a pedicure this is as good as it's gonna
get let me take a picture oh yeah and
then oh you know what can you see it on
the youtube i don't want to give it away
for free
oh that's a nice but
only fans only foot only one foot
um so that is your toasters thank you to
everyone who wrote in for being
vulnerable with us and if you want to
write into your toasters at gmail.com
that is our show it is we actually have
to rap because we have a busy day
podcast meetings meetings podcast
podcast podcast we're recording doing
four podcasts today yeah that's crazy
shouldn't we listen
because we're doing this one check then
we're going on skinny confidentials
podcast him and her we're so excited we
need to go there now we're out pretty
running late
we're recording with them for tmt so
stay tuned for that i think that'll be
up tomorrow yes and then claudia and i
are recording a patreon episode all
about
books we just feel like we've been
talking a lot about books we should
dedicate a whole it's not going to be
like a mini red heads but i just want to
catch up with all the books we've read
and reading systems
like i feel like i get so many messages
that are like where's the verity recap
where are seven husbands of evelyn where
are our like official lists i'm gonna go
through my goodreads and make my
official like five-star four-star
three-star list yes exactly so that we
can share that with all of you so if you
have any book questions reach out before
we record um but we're just gonna get
we're gonna get into it so we have to go
meetings meet these meetings hope you
guys enjoyed this episode thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so spotify itunes
or public radio i have ready to start
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find out somebody show
supervisor review
and smart we are hope you guys have a
great day if you're still listening to
the society season two leave um foot
emoji is there a photo emoji i think so
the food emoji on our instagram have a
great day love you bye bye
you